national study says college enrollment
is down five percent since 2019 so some
students are questioning the value of a
traditional four-year degree bianca
holman is live this morning at unlv with
a look at what some experts have to say
about this bianca good morning to
you hey good morning john good morning
everybody so this is that time of year
high school seniors they're being asked
what are you going to do after
graduation right well a couple of years
ago it might have definitely been well
i'm going to go to this school
university but now in present day a lot
of students have alternative options so
there was actually a survey it was a
survey by the company called instructure
instructor the maker of canvas this is a
learning system that many school
districts use use including ccsd and
unlv the company conducted a survey with
students about 70 percent of respondents
said having definable skills is more
important than course titles or degree
the student debt crisis actually created
some of the the concern we're seeing now
with declining enrollment and and
students are really looking for ways to
to connect to jobs down the road and so
really looking at that return on their
investments in ways they didn't
previously
so we took a look at unlv's enrollment
it's been pretty consistent above 30
thousand students every year but it's
down slightly this school year compared
to fall 2020 and also looking at those
numbers a little bit deeper less
students enrolled in undergraduate
degrees while more enrolled in some
certificate or specialized programs and
so coming up in the next half hour we're
going to take a look at nevada state
college and the enrollment there back to
you guys in the studio